pris du poids de la villardière un peu
c'est vraiment un et tous ses voyages
non c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'ont dit
les voyages forment la jeunesse
dis donc qu'est ce que c'est que ça nous
na na kwa
c'est dans mes gènes peut par arrêté tu
m'avais promis d'arrêter je ne peux pas
reste que tu me coûte en huile de jojoba
au point qu'ils écoulent mon stock
allait passer ma minouche le nouveau
resto mia viatique mes talents des fallu
saloperie ben oui mais ça ne fonctionne
pas ça ne fonctionne pas puisque je pige
pas quoi au badge est juste en train de
regarder la dise quoi pas minutes put
you remind side and press the button
mais ça veut dire quoi appuyer sur un
bouton mais bon c'est ça les boutons
qu'est ce que disent après l'icône de
side and shake gym tout et ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire qu'apparemment ils
font il faut envoyer un chèque mais sous
quinzaine et mais il y met pas la bresse
ain fort finish expérience un greeter
sense en tête au niveau national et ça
ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que tu
m'emmerdes et non pas aux lola vient
d'un seul tube à sa suite red a compris
ça ta grâce à des faux culs jamais
tac tac c'est qui ces gens jean king
gens ne tient pas debout